welcome to hot topics
computing at MIT I'm Dan Hutton Walker
the Dean of the Schwartzman college of
computing we're really delighted to have
Brad Smith the president and also the
chief legal officer at Microsoft while
many of us see technology as a
double-edged sword as technologists we
often tend to see the opportunity and
the potential for good and new
technologies maybe blinding us to the
other other edge of the sword Brad
really stands out in his ability to
articulate the balance of positive and
negative impacts from technologies and
how to get better outcomes overall from
understanding and addressing these in
advance he's really transformed how
Microsoft and much of the tech industry
see computing technology growing out of
the Department of Justice actions
against Microsoft at the 1990s he began
framing the tech challenges as well as
the opportunities of new technologies in
ways that technology leaders could
appreciate he successfully brought bill
gates one of the great technology
leaders of the 20th century on this
journey and I would say instilling in
him and the company the important roles
of many societal and government actors
as we think about technology I think
that we have a lot to learn from Brad
well I know that we're gonna learn a lot
in today's fireside chat I also really
highly recommend his recent book tools
and weapons
it has compelling even I would say
page-turning vignettes each of which
makes deeper and important points about
technology and it's positive and
negative impacts we have about 250
questions that participants submitted in
advance we'll be getting to some of the
more frequent ones of those and you can
also enter questions at the bottom of
your screen brad is going to be joined
by Daniela Rus in this fireside chat
she's the deputy dean of academics here
in the Schwartzman college and the
director of C so I'm sure we're in for a
great conversation Danielle and bread
thank you Dan
we are so excited to welcome Brad Smith
to our virtual campus today our teams
for
discuss this event in the winter and
this feels so long ago by now because
Brad there's been so much happening in
these past few months that has had a big
imprint on technology and so I'm really
eager to get into this conversation
we have many MIT students with us today
and they submitted over 200 questions so
let's get started now first I saw that
your CEO Satya Nadella said that
Microsoft has seen two years worth of
digital transformation in two months and
all sorts of organizations are working
on kovat related research I'd like to
start by asking you what do you view as
the biggest challenges Microsoft has
faced so far and what lessons have you
learned well first Thank You Daniella
thank you dan and and thanks to
everybody for watching this I I I do
want to just open by saying how much we
at Microsoft appreciate the opportunity
to work with all of you at MIT and
frankly how much we learn from working
with all of you it's such an important
relationship and partnership for us Eric
or what's leads a lot of the work here
to work with you all and including on
the issues that we'll be talking about
today around the trustworthy and ethical
artificial intelligence and other
technology but I do think let's start
with the obvious this is a time unlike
any in our lifetime you literally have
to go back 102 years to find a pandemic
that has had we reach that kovat 19 has
I think it's interesting to think about
how different the world's response is in
the year 2020 not just compared to 1918
but just imagine if this had happened in
2010 or 2005 in so many ways the world
has gone digital and this event itself I
think really illustrates that you know
interestingly for us at Microsoft having
our own people work from home has not
been that difficult Trevor Noah joked
with me we work to get
a number of things that just we were
sort of practicing for this everyday
just by being Microsoft by developing
this technology that we use every day
but our role throughout this has really
been to support all of the other
organizations and institutions
government's nonprofits businesses
literally on a global scale that have
had to transition to so much more remote
work and one of the interesting things
you realize and I think it speaks to
sort of the multi-faceted aspects of
technology that we're talking about
today is that of course you start with
the technology itself now what is it
that people want to deploy is it teams
is it more cloud services yeah that is
sort of a natural starting point but
then you immediately realize that you
can't deploy that without fundamentally
changing business processes government
processes we've seen the Ministry of
Justice in Italy take all of its trials
online we've seen so many companies take
so many of their business processes
customer delivery processes online and
so we have to work hand-in-hand with
them if we're not a company that can
just say here's the tech good luck let
us know how it turns out
we work with them to then customize
their solutions that work on top of our
platform and then there's one final
aspect that I think has been so
interesting it's the old adage that you
need a clear strategy but ultimately
culture eats strategy for breakfast I
think this has been Illustrated really
interestingly in our schools including
our public schools in the United States
I think they've struggled in many states
they don't have the connectivity for
students at home they don't have the
devices but even when they do all of
that you really realize you have to work
with teachers they need to learn not
just how to use the technology but to
create a culture for a classroom when
the students aren't in the room and so
it's not just a huge technology
challenge it's an enormous human child
and I think the great opportunity for us
has been the ability to just stand next
to our customers and sort of walk a mile
in their shoes so that we can try to
explore all of this together you know
that's been just an extraordinary
opportunity for learning for us are
there particular efforts you have been
most proud of with respect to this work
well I think in the short run this is a
public health crisis it's a public
health crisis that has created a
profound economic crisis but I'd start
with public health I think one of the
things that has emerged is that data has
become the indispensable tool to address
the public health aspects of this um
think about the decisions that governors
are making in the United States now
they've never impacted our life even
remotely as much as they have in recent
months they're running the economy
they're deciding who can leave their
house and who needs to stay home but
they are decisions that need to be based
on data data about the spread of the
infection in about hospital capacity you
know data about different counties in
the state and you know the mortality
that is being seen and the like and so
we've worked very closely with the
counties and states in the United States
with national governments and with the
World Health Organization to really
transform the way they are collecting
data the way they're reporting it the
way they're sharing it with other
leaders the way they're sharing it with
the public so that has been just sort of
one of the slices I've seen in the
public health space I think another
really interesting example does come
from the AI kinds of technologies that
you all at MIT have been so involved in
it has been sort of a moment of real
importance for conversational AI you
know we had developed an AI a chat bot
that was being deployed by a hospital
here in Seattle well it's now being
deployed by over 1500 institutions in 23
countries that's amazing
yeah and basically what it does is it
allows an individual who may think they
might need a coven 19 tests to go
through a conversation that will begin
to determine whether they in fact do and
if so it can hand off the individual to
a human via telehealth service but in
April that was used 190 million times so
just think about that yeah that
explosion that is I think a great
manifestation of two years of
digitization taking place in two months
that's truly extraordinary and now let
me stay with copa-data for a minute and
ask you so I know you've said that you
are skeptical about the use of contact
tracing and I'm just wondering what
leads you to believe this is the case
well first of all contact tracing is a
fundamental importance in the case of
any communicable disease now I will be
quick to say I say this as a person who
on New Year's Eve could have written
down perhaps everything I knew about
Public Health on the back of a postage
stamp you know this has been a crash
course for all of us but certainly what
we learn from the present and from the
past is that for over a century whenever
anybody has a disease that is spread in
an infectious way you know they're
interviewed by a public health officer
and you're basically part of the routine
is where have you been who did you see
and the public health officer then
contacts typically by phone or email
each of those individuals that is a
process that is fundamentally important
now we're talking about deploying apps
for that I think that's a good thing
don't get me wrong I think that app
based contact tracing is an important
tool but I think we should recognize
that it is a tool and not a panacea it
is in my view sort of a belt and
suspenders approach we still will need
public health officers to interview each
in an individual who test positive over
the phone or in person
even if they've been using an app on
their smartphone that has say something
like blue truth based contact data on it
why well the first reason is not
everybody is going to walk around with
an app on their phone in Western Europe
in North America it's very clear
governments are not going to make this
mandatory even in Singapore where it's
not mandatory but they have exhorted the
population to use this technology
they've struggled to get it above a 20
percent adoption rate the second thing
to just remember is even if you could
get everybody who has a phone to use the
app not everybody has a following some
of the most vulnerable people in this
pandemic are homeless people they're
people who are elderly in nursing homes
so we just can't base our planning on
the assumption that everyone will have
this app finally we need to recognize
this is a smart phone we're talking
about it's not an ankle bracelet people
forget to take it with them to the
grocery store the battery dies so I
think it's an important tool I think
it's a very valuable I think it can make
life easier and it can make this whole
approach to contact tracing more
effective but it won't replace the
humans who need to do this contact
tracing and frankly it won't replace the
need for individuals who test positive
still to go through a lengthy interview
what about privacy with respect to
contact tracing is that a concern oh I
think it absolutely is and I think it's
an important thing for us to focus on
and I think it's the kind of thing that
should call on us both narrowly and
broadly to remember we need to address
some new problems but we don't need to
throw what I would call timeless values
out the window to do so a few weeks ago
we published you know seven privacy
principles and in some ways I think some
of them reflect the degree to which you
can harmonize say the protection of
privacy and the protection of Public
Health
and then you can get to the issues that
where there may be some real tension
between them but for example if we are
using this app and this data to protect
public health I don't think it's a
stretch to save them the only proper use
of the data is to protect public health
and I don't think it's a stretch to tell
people that their data will not be
retained beyond the point in time in
which it's actually useful to protect
public health those are two principles
where I think we can actually advance
both causes at the same time there are
other areas where there are certain
tensions but we believe these can mostly
be reconciled and and we think we can do
this in a way that by and large strongly
upholds the protection of privacy and I
think that should be our goal so this is
a great segue to talking about your book
tools and weapons which I finished
reading over the weekend and I enjoyed
it very much
the book read to me like an
action-adventure book with geeks as the
heroes so thank you for that so to me
the book summarizes your views on the
roles companies should take in in having
a more immoral stance on how technology
is viewed and used and the book also
includes some great historical context I
loved the backstories for events I
remember for instance failing to track
Daniel Pearl's
kidnappers successfully finding Charlie
Hebdo attackers and and hearing about
how the your CEO Satya Nadella decided
that the security patches for one a
Christ should be broadly available to
the public and so my first question is
what inspired you to write this book and
what did you want to communicate to the
public with it well first of all thank
you for reading it I do find that when
you do an event like this it it
encourages people to finish it the
weekend before we talk so thank you I
love your description because I do
you're right in our minds geeks are the
heroes of a lot of dramas that involve
very important in human problems
Caroline Brown is my co-author we work
together at Microsoft and we really
wrote the book to try to reach a broader
audience to bring these stories to life
to let people see how they have been
addressed in practice not just at
Microsoft but in many other places as
well to draw on some lessons from
history because in our mind yet the the
tool of the book really captures the
challenge we think we face digital
technology I think is the world's most
powerful tool for so many huge problems
but it has become a formidable weapon as
well and so our ultimate goal is to
broaden the conversation that we think
the world needs to have about where
technology is going how it needs to be
managed and how it needs to actually
build on the geeks who are the heroes
but now you recognize that we're at a
point where these issues are broad
importance for everybody you don't have
to be a student at MIT you don't need to
have a PhD in computer science to have
an important role to play these issues
affect all of us and if nothing else as
consumers as citizens and as voters you
know we're at a point in time where I
think we all benefit if everyone is
better informed so let's dig a little
bit a little bit deeper in your book you
say that the two inflection points of
this decade are Cambridge analytic ah
and Edward Snowden's revelations can you
elaborate why what makes these events so
important in your mind well if you look
back at the period from 2010 to 2020
I do think these were two inflection
points the the Snowden disclosures
happened in the summer of 2013 and what
they did more than anything else I think
is awake
the public not just in the United States
but around the world to the degree to
which governments had access to so much
data about each and every one of us and
it led to a effort to reform government
surveillance and create more protection
for people one of the fascinating
moments for me is a story we share in
the book it was being in the Roosevelt
Room in the West Wing of the White House
at a meeting in December of 2013 with
President Obama Vice President Biden the
White House senior staff and 18 leading
tech executives and as each of us were
pushing President Obama to reform
government surveillance there came this
interesting moment when he looked around
the table and he said I just want you
all to recognize you all have more data
about people than the government does
and he said I have a suspicion that the
guns will turn and there will be a
moment when the demands that you're
placing on the government will be placed
on you as well I thought it was a very
insightful comment at the time I wrote
it down I looked around and I was struck
no one else was writing it down and that
moment came it came it took five years
which would have been frankly longer
than I predicted it at the time but it
took 2018 and it was Cambridge
analytical I think for a variety of
reasons that we describe in the book
that is the moment when then the public
focused more on the amount of data that
tech companies have on them and it's
really a watershed political moment in
my view because it started to unleash
more scrutiny of tech companies
certainly in the United States but
equally important perhaps even more
important on the global basis so data
bring us back to privacy considerations
you have a wonderful chapter in your
book that presents privacy as a human
right and you start this chapter on
privacy by describing your experience in
Berlin when you visited the headquarters
of Stasi
and for me this was a very powerful
moment of the book since I was born in
Romania during spotty like times you
also say that this was one of the most
memorable moments of that year for you
how is this how did this experience of
visiting the Stasi headquarters impact
your views on privacy as a human right
well it really was a moving moment for
the for me for for Carolyn and for
others from Microsoft were on this
physic you know in what was East Berlin
the former Stasi prison is now a museum
and you know we had the opportunity to
walk through the prison with an
individual who was a prisoner there in
1968 you know he's a lot like a lot of
us who are all connected here today in
1968 he was 24 years old his name is
Hans Jochen Schuyler
he was pursuing a graduate degree in
physics at the time he was studying at
the University University of Prague and
1968 was the year of the Prague Spring
well he was back in Berlin when the
Warsaw Pact tanks rolled through Prague
to shut down the liberalisation that was
taking place there he and three of his
friends were very upset about this so
they printed up these little leaflets
and they handed them out to people one
evening he was reported to the Stasi
they picked him up that night they took
him to this prison where for many many
months he never saw another human being
except for the individuals who were
interrogating them he was never given
the opportunity to read anything he was
never given the opportunity to write his
parents have no idea what had happened
to him but when you think about what put
him there in the first place it was this
extraordinary degree of surveillance
that the Stasi had unleashed on the
people of East Germany using all of the
technology
and hundreds of thousands of informants
and when you think about what he did he
wrote a few lines and he handed it out
to people well in our day
that's called sending a text message
it's called writing an email and with
cloud computing and online services we
now live in a world where if we're not
careful any government can use the power
of technology to unleash surveillance on
a scale that the Stasi could not have
imagined and you see what can happen
when that kind of power is abused and I
think it's just really important for us
to use that as inspiration one of the
most interesting moments for me was to
share a short video that we produced we
had a camera crew with us on that visit
and we have an annual sales meeting at
Microsoft it's in the t-mobile Arena in
Las Vegas you're speaking to 15,000
people and as you can imagine at a sales
meeting mostly it's this was a great
year we're doing really well everybody's
so enthusiastic and I showed that video
and I frankly worried you know I was
like well this is a bit of a downer is
this gonna land well but I thought it
was so important for our employees to
see that through their own eyes and I
will frankly always remember not just
the visit to the museum and the prison
but the standing ovations of all of our
employees you know to me I think this is
the message for everybody who's watching
now it is our time and it is really
going to be your generation that will
disseminate how this technology impacts
people's rights around the world and I
think we have to learn from the past and
frankly just resolve together that we
won't allow that kind of thing to be
repeated Brad that's so powerful to me
let me follow up with a question on well
you see the role of Technology and of
the legal system
to ensure privacy as a human right well
I think two things need to go together
first yep just as technology can be
weaponized as that last example showed
it is a powerful tool for the protection
of human rights you know we're using it
for example with George and Amal Clooney
Amal Clooney is one of the great human
rights lawyers in the world and with the
Clooney foundation for justice we've
created a cloud service in an app so
that monitors can go into courtrooms
around the world court rooms were
journalists or or women or people from
the LGBT community are potentially being
persecuted and then prosecuted in ways
that put their rights at risk and you
can capture data you can share it with
the world you can ensure that that trial
is evaluated by judicial experts in
other countries all of that is happening
that's just one small example of all of
the ways that technology can be used I
think to promote the protection of human
rights but I do think at the end of the
day you know there is no substitute for
protection under the law itself
protection by judges and courts and so a
lot of what we need to focus on is how
technology and the law can advance
together to meet these broad needs
that's really one of the other things
that inspired us to write this book yes
and technology and law need to
understand each other's language and
capabilities in order to make that path
forward together now a related issue to
privacy security and you are
instrumental in guiding microsoft word
building a strong security foundation
and you decided that Microsoft needed to
be the most secure company and held your
ground on this which was visionary and
courageous especially at a time when
people did not really care about the
privacy of their data and other
companies were better
on advertising I'm just wondering about
the backstory how did you decide on the
importance of security well I think
security became so fundamentally
important beginning in about the year
2000 you know software was designed for
the personal computer but no one
envisioned that the personal computer
would always be connected to the world
and so we recognized that that was what
was going to take place and we saw the
attacks that started to take place and
so we started to harden computers we
started the hardened network
architecture and software yeah and what
we really then learned was that we
needed to keep pace and we needed to
rely not just on technology to protect
people but we were going to need to work
with governments and new ways we were
going to need to work with the rest of
the industry we were going to need to
advocate for stronger laws around the
world and so it was really that
combination that I think led us to you
know put ourselves on a journey it's a
journey that continues today we continue
to see nation-states becoming more
aggressive and so we're having to figure
out exactly what new initiatives we need
to take you know it's institutions at
MIT that of course play an
extraordinarily important role as well
we're all in this together and we're all
focused when acting together Brad with
elections coming up this fall a lot of
states and counties are talking about
the possibility of voting apps what's
your take on the security of electronic
voting well I think the interesting
thing is in a world where we take for
granted security for financial
transactions every day we're not yet in
a world where we have you know security
for elections and voting the way we
would like and so you know what I think
we're going to need to do is look
towards the future where we frankly can
have online voting why not but it is
going to take time to be able to deploy
it well I think one of the things to
just recognize it
we engage in financial transactions
every moment of the day there's billions
every day
voting happens infrequently it's a
powerful reminder that just in life we
get better at things that we do
frequently than things that we do rarely
but I think we need to put ourselves on
an ongoing quest to develop more secure
online voting solutions in the meantime
what we urgently need to do is secure
the voting systems that exist today in
so many places in the United States we
have voting machines that are 10 or 15
years old and so one of the really
urgent needs including for this election
year is to keep working typically with
municipalities with counties with States
to harden their voting systems now you
have a powerful chapter on AI and
democracy in your book and you also
warned about about a potential digital
911 what are you doing to prevent this
meaning what is Microsoft doing to
prevent this well first of all I would
just say if you think about what a
digital 911 would be I think it's two
things one is it would be a government
attacking attacking say so that the
electrical grid goes down hospitals go
down that is what happened in 2017 with
wanna cry and the National Health
Service in the United Kingdom a third of
their hospitals went down cash registers
ATMs everything stops working that's
what happened in Ukraine with the not
petty attack but ultimately I think one
of the worst attacks could be if we
learned a week after an election that
voting had been tampered with that the
voting rolls had been tampered with I
think if something like that were to
happen then you know I think we'd have a
real issue I mean just think what it
would mean if no-one had confidence to
know who had been elected president that
would be you know a fundamental problem
our entire basis for society I think
would be put at risk
I couldn't agree with you more and I'm
so glad that Microsoft and many other
organizations and researchers including
a lot of researchers at MIT are working
on the challenge of security I'd like to
turn over to a different topic and that
is regulation and I was very intrigued
because in your book you make an
argument that I think it's a bit rare
among executives of major tech companies
and that is that Silicon Valley needs
more regulation and so I wonder can we
get specific in what particular areas do
you think companies like Microsoft need
more regulation well first of all I
think we should recognize broadly that a
well-functioning market typically has
room for lots of innovation lots of room
for entrepreneurialship but a layer of
regulation you know we have more
confidence in the safety of food and
drugs because of the FDA we have more
confidence in the safety of our cars and
aircraft because of regulatory
authorities so when you put things in
that lens I do believe that digital
technology has reached a point where it
would benefit from more regulation not
the kind of regulation that would stifle
creativity but I do think to protect
privacy I think to protect security I
think too we ensure the responsible use
of artificial intelligence that's why
we've called for regulation of facial
recognition technology we now have the
first example about a state law passed
in Washington State
I think not coincidentally where
Microsoft is base so we have all of that
to learn from I think digital safety the
protection of children that's another
obvious area all of these I think are
right for regulation and that's why
we're seeing more regulation in it I
will say you're going to get a kick out
of this Microsoft is so good at
protecting security that my company's
policies are telling me that they're
going to reboot my computer and
minutes I'm listening to you I am trying
to find a way to disable that which I
may or may not find in the next seven
minutes so this will be one of the more
memorable security updates in my life if
this in fact happened so let's I hope
not I I have not gotten too many of the
200 questions but let me ask you
something about China so Microsoft has
had a direct presence in China for a
long time your R&D initiatives there are
significant can you tell us a bit about
your experience there and how the
current and foreseeable political
disputes between you and US and China
are affecting you if I don't know I
think they're affecting all of us I
think it really has a three-part impact
first it's having an impact on supply
chain stability and yeah I think there
are real questions for the future as to
the degree to which American tech
companies will be able to rely on the
Chinese supply chain for hardware a
second it's having an impact on access
to the Chinese market I think the
Chinese market has really provided only
limited access to most of American tech
companies and that doesn't look like
it's going to change in fact I think it
may get harder rather than easier but
and finally I actually think the single
most important thing for us to think
about the the thing that's most
important for Microsoft I would argue
for MIT it's the intellectual
interaction now China as we all know has
some of the world's greatest engineers
software developers academics you know
software is not created in only a single
country especially with open-source
techniques and the like it's created by
people working together and even if
supply chains change even if access to
the market is limited I think it's a
profound importance to the world that
people be able to learn and study and
research and think together and I think
preserving that amid these other
challenges is really an important
priority
all of us what about a digital iron
curtain' you talk in the chapter about
China about the possibility of a digital
Iron Curtain we've also heard former
Google CEO Eric Schmidt talk about
splintering the Internet into one
Chinese led and one non Chinese led what
would be the geopolitical and economic
impact of the splintering and how do you
see the creation of this digital Iron
Curtain well I think the world has been
splintering since 2010 you know the
internet in China is not the same as the
internet in the United States but I
think what we now see more and more is
obviously a degree of technology
competition between the United States
and China we see public policies in both
countries focused on this competition I
think you know increasingly American
companies have an advantage in the
United States Chinese companies have an
advantage China they compete with each
other in Europe and elsewhere you know
we'll see you know it is increasingly a
bipolar technology world that's the
phrase we use in our book this will be I
think one of the defining issues for
this decade and a lot remains unknown
about how exactly this is going to
unfold we've talked about a lot of
challenges there is one big challenge
that is impacting everyone and that is
climate change I personally believe that
our only way out of this this big
challenge is to figure out how to cool
the planet by one degree rather than
figuring out how to not warm up by more
than another one and a half degrees and
I was inspired when earlier this year
Microsoft announced ambitious plans to
go carbon- by 2030 not only that but
also to turn back the clock on all the
carbon Microsoft has produced since 1975
by counterbalancing that number by 2050
what do you see as the biggest challenge
as you proceed with a subjective
well we're buried at first of all we
need a broad public understanding and
commitment to the goal I think the goal
needs to get to be carbon zero meaning
Net Zero by 2050 meaning as a planet
we're removing every year as much carbon
as we emit now to do that then two
things become obvious we need to emit
less carbon and we need to remove more
we need a number of techniques to emit
less carbon
well digital technology plays a powerful
role in our ability to measure this to
create standards ultimately to reinforce
this through private action and I think
public regulation in a way that will
drive emissions down but I think we also
need a massive investment perhaps the
biggest R&D challenge of the century to
develop new techniques to remove carbon
from the environment things like direct
air capture are so clearly in their
infancy they're not yet cost-effective
and we're going to need just huge
breakthroughs in that space over the
next three decades if we are going to
achieve this fundamental goal of
protecting the planet the way we need to
and we have a tragedy of the Commons
here many more companies have to step up
and follow a Microsoft's lead on this
because everyone needs to pitch in
otherwise we won't get there no we do
and I'm just gonna say now in case you
lose me in one minute thank you for the
45 minutes rather than the hour but
let's hope that I keep going with my
minutes I I'd like to switch to some
questions by ultimate speed round
okay so here's one how can workers for
actively expand on their skills to adapt
to the increasingly digital AI driven
environment well I would say two things
people who are not in the computer and
data science field need to master more
digital skills but my plea to all of you
because I think so many of you probably
are more in the computer and data fields
is don't neglect the other aspects of
the liberal arts make sure that you're
in a position to not only help drive
technology forward but to think more
broadly about the use cases the
fundamental societal problems you can
help solve the ethical but almost the
philosophical issues the policy issues
the legal issues that will also need to
be addressed in order to advance
technology in a way that genuinely is
going to best serve the world
I think only if we're able to think in a
more multidisciplinary framework than we
have in the past are we going to be
successful in ensuring that technology
serves the public in the way it really
broadly needs to do this is definitely
the spirit of MIT s college of computing
okay next question does Microsoft have
plans to allow people to work from home
permanently like Twitter recently
announced ok I I wonder if we should
wait for a minute
to see if Brad can rejoin us otherwise I
hope you've enjoyed that the
conversation I certainly have learned so
much from Brad's wisdom I encourage all
of you to to read his book it's really a
tour de force through many ethical
challenges that we we as a community
face around the use of technology so
let's see there's some questions both
are posted on Q&A and I am going to wait
for just a minute to see if anybody is
oh look Brad is back excellent
we are so excited to see you run away
[Laughter]
[Music]
let me just say and Microsoft you know
we've first told people hey you feel
comfortable working from home through
October until the beginning of November
I think your real question is what does
the future look like
when kovat 19 is a memory I think will
have more people working from home I
still think we're going to have offices
yo Satya Nadella our CEO if they put it
really well at a conversation here and
yesterday he said let's not replace one
dogma with another the old dogma was
everybody needs to be in the office
let's not create a new dogma that says
no one should ever see each other in
person we can all do things through
these screens I think that what we're
gonna find is more choices for more
people we'll see the technology
continued to advance certainly we're
working to accelerate the pace of
innovation for our products like teams
but I do think that at the end of the
day there is something important about
seeing each other in person there's
these conversations that happened before
a meeting begins after a class ends I
think there are still important things
that happen when people sit down and you
know have lunch together
yeah so we should keep all of that in
mind I think we're going to live in a
world that has more of what we call
remote everything there will be more
remote digital services but I think our
ultimate goal should be to bring out the
best of what that offers and the best of
what we as human beings get by being
able to spend time together in person so
the next question is how you envision
the world in the next 10 to 20 years you
touched upon how we're gonna work a post
covet
what about living and playing and
learning well in addition to working at
Microsoft every day I'm on the board of
Netflix so I get to see things from that
perspective as well and and let's face
it
you know this isn't just something of
the last couple of months where we're
all relying on remote entertainment but
you know we've been seeing this change
over the course of a number of years
yeah clearly the use of digital
technology is going to be one of the
defining trends of the 2020s as it
really was for the 2010s
but what I would say is that well it has
so much potential to bring improvements
to people's lives we also do need to
think hard about the inequalities the
technology can create you know income
inequality has become one of the really
important issues in the United States
and many other countries in digital
technology to some degree has
exacerbated that in part because we're
seeing tech companies do so well in all
honesty you know businesses that are not
grounded in technology have had a harder
time but I think it is broader than that
I think we live in a world with internet
inequality you see this very sharply
when you see the tens of millions of
Americans that don't have access to
broadband I think we live in a world of
educational inequality and digital
skills in the heighten need for digital
skills is shining a spotlight on that I
think we live in a world where digital
technology can do so much but it can
exacerbate the inequalities for example
but people with disabilities may
confront especially if we don't do a
great job of designing technology to
meet their needs so I think that these
inequalities of the world will be one of
the important issues of this decade
they're all going to be more pronounced
because of this extraordinary recession
if not depression emerging from Kovan 19
and I think for all of us who you know
aspired to have geeks as the heroes as
you say
I think we need geeks to be heroes and
we need teachers to be heroes and we
need public officials to be heroes
because if we're not careful these
advances in technology will make the
inequalities greater rather than smaller
so let me try to get a few more audience
questions in what do you see as the role
of Microsoft in the open-source
community well you know one of the more
interesting few pages in our book I
would say certainly for those of us who
are involved in experiencing it and for
carol anne and i when we wrote about it
because we you know acknowledged very
directly that Microsoft is the say in
the book was on the wrong side of
history when the open source really
exploded at the beginning of this
century and I can say that not just
about Microsoft I can say it about me
personally the good news is if life is
long enough and you're successful in
other areas you can be on the wrong side
of history and learn that you're there
and you need to change and that's what
we did today Microsoft is the single
largest contributor to open source
projects in the world at least when it
comes to businesses and we're very proud
of that when we look at github we see
github as the home for open source
development and we have a responsibility
as a steward to make it a great and
secure and productive home for the
world's open-source developers so you
know we're much more now in the
open-source camp than outside it even if
not every piece of code that we write is
developed as part of an open-source
project I think in some ways one of the
other really interesting questions for
all of us is how do we learn from open
source and apply that learning to what
we now refer to as open data we launched
just a few weeks ago what we're calling
an open data campaign a global effort
that we think really needs to be focused
on ensuring that more data sets perhaps
especially data sets that relate to
great societal issue
are opened up yes so we've created five
principles that were applying to
ourselves in the data that we have were
investing in more work with nonprofits
we're promoting public policy ultimately
I think the great need in the world is
to ensure that those that have smaller
data sets whether they be companies
small businesses universities or the
like have the opportunity to scale by
federating their data with datasets held
by other institutions but there is a
clear need to do so with the kinds of
platform and tools that a company like
Microsoft creates it isn't imperative to
protect privacy
we're very enthused about new techniques
like differential privacy and where we
see that technology going there needs to
be the recognition that people need to
be able to share data without
surrendering their ownership or control
of it there's a lot here that is very
broad and I think this is another area
that's really right for progress in a
place like MIT ok so if you were still
in today what would be your major you
know I majored as I said I'm the liberal
arts side of liberal arts meets
engineering and Microsoft I I like to
quote Steve Jobs who said that he worked
every day at the intersection between
engineering and the liberal arts it is a
way of reminding us all that in fact we
need the kind of multidisciplinary
approach that I was talking about before
I majored in international relations at
Princeton you know that I'd probably
major again if I could in history you
know I have just found it remarkably
helpful for somebody who does the work
that I do to be able to learn from the
past but you know one of the interesting
things about history is that ultimately
there's sort of the history of
everything including the history of
science the history of Technology I
definitely would not be the kind of
student that would study only one thing
one of the great things you realize
later on in life is that when you're in
a university
it's an enormous opportunity to study
lots of other things and so that's what
I would encourage people to do Brad
there is a lot of uncertainty in the
world right now and a lot of reasons
people feel anxious on the flip side I'm
just curious what motivates you and what
makes your clock tick and get up and and
open the day you know with an exciting
outlook every morning well look this is
a hard time let's just recognize the
obvious even for those of us who have
the great good fortune to have jobs to
not be among the 36 million Americans
who filed for unemployment claims in the
last three months to be among the people
who are healthy this is a challenging
time but I also think that because of
the challenging times that we confront
the truth is the world has never needed
digital technology to do as much as it
needs it to do right now and even when
kovat 19 is a memory it will become a
memory you know we're not going to be
talking about koban 19 in 2030 as much
as well be talking about Carla and I
suspect the world will need the kind of
technology we can create and when I say
we I don't mean we at Microsoft I mean
all of us who are having this
conversation I mean all of you who are
getting a degree at MIT right now this
is the future that you're going to
create and you have a bigger opportunity
I think to have a more important and
more positive impact in the world than
perhaps any generation that has ever
studied at MIT has had before because
digital technology is just ubiquitous in
the world and the opportunity to ensure
that it not only works well but it does
good for the world oh my gosh how can
you not be excited about getting up in
the morning that's sort of what I feel
and you know I just didn't frankly so
happy I've had the opportunity to work
with great scientists and engineers
on technology that matters and I really
hope that all of you will as well it's
something that should inspire all of us
I believe well this is a fantastic
advice for our students thank you for
that if you go back 40 years in
hindsight what advice from a global
leader would have been most useful for
you at that time you know I work with
Bill Gates Steve Ballmer Satya Nadella
I've had the opportunity to meet a lot
of great world leaders you know in my
job the one thing that I find truly
successful people have in common is
enormous curiosity and I think it's
something that if you're at a place like
MIT you probably have already but the
advice I would give is it's like a
muscle exercise it use it push yourself
to read more listen more learn more in
more fields start with what is at the
core of what is your major or focus in
graduate education but keep adding to
that and what you'll find I think is two
things one is there are more dots that
you can connect them you can ever would
have imagined more things relate to each
other as you broaden the aperture but
the second thing is life is just more
fun when you ask people questions it's a
lot more interesting when you get to
learn from other people and you know
develop that sense of curiosity it's not
only something that will make you more
successful I think it will make your
life more enjoyable and I benefited from
a lot of similar advice so I think I
heard some of that when I was a student
but if I could go back in time I would
write a little note to myself and I
probably read it every morning
well I'm inspired and unfortunately we
are at the top of the hour with you and
we will have to save the other questions
for the future so I would like to take
this opportunity
- thank you for sharing your wisdom and
insights with us and also give you an
open invitation to come back for an
in-person visit to our campus when we
are open for business again I look
forward to being there in person I
always enjoy my visits it's great to
connect digitally but it's even more fun
to be there in person so thank you
Thank You Brad
for joining us today and thank you
daniela for moderating is truly
fascinating and really deeply
informative conversation which i knew it
would be in advance but it's great to
see it actually realized and in fact
even the little temporary gap in the
middle at least for me it gave me a
little bit of time to catch up because
just this constant sort of pacing of
questions and answers i needed a little
processing time so it just thank thank
you so much
really fantastic just one house good
thing while you were catching up i was
panicking with 20/20 hindsight microsoft
we make software secure yep well but
this is the world if we're going to be
more secure if security isn't first it
never happens so it's actually a good
lesson you know we always put it off
otherwise but just one housekeeping
thing we'll be posting a video today's
event on both the sea sale and the
college of computing websites once we
have the time to get it closed captioned
so thank you all everybody especially in
these times take care and be well thank
you for joining us thank you thank you